John Podesta used to see a lot of classified documents in his old job as White House Chief of Staff under President Clinton.
约翰·波德斯塔在克林顿总统任期内担任白宫幕僚长时，曾接触过大量机密文件。
You go from the range of, you slap your head and say, holy cow, I can't believe we know this, and you absolutely know why it's classified, all the way down the stream to-- I've seen, literally, newspaper reports classified. AP wire copy classified.
你的经历从让你拍案叫绝、惊呼“天哪，我们竟然知道这个”，并且完全明白为什么要将其列为机密，一直到最后发现——我甚至亲眼见过报纸报道被列为机密。美联社的电讯稿也被列为机密。
Wait, wait. Literally, the report from the paper?
等等，等等。真的是报纸上的报道？
Yeah. Yeah, that's then been classified and forwarded on to the president, for example.
是的。是的，这些报道后来被列为机密，并转呈给总统，例如这样。
Even back then, during an administration that declassified 800 million documents, that tried to release any government document possible under the Freedom of Information Act, even back then a lot of stuff that stayed secret just did not really need to be secret. It's just the way government works. And so, under the current administration, the Bush administration, there's probably also stuff that does not really need to be classified.
即使在当年，在一个解密了8亿份文件、试图在《信息自由法》下尽可能公开政府文件的政府治下，那时很多保持秘密的东西其实根本没有必要保密。这就是政府运作的方式。所以，在现任布什政府治下，可能也存在很多根本不需要被列为机密的东西。
In putting together today's radio program, I've tried to compile a list of all the new things the government is keeping secret. And there are so many of them, I do not even know if I've got them all. Are you ready? There is the vice president in a lawsuit over whether he has to release the names of people that he met with in forming his energy policy. There's the executive order that lets former presidents keep more of their old documents secret. There's the official Bush administration policy not to release any document under the Freedom of Information Act if there is any legal way to avoid it. Committee chairmen in Congress-- these are Republicans, mind you, Republicans-- are complaining publicly that they cannot get information out of the administration, out of the agencies that they are supposed to be overseeing.
在筹备今天的广播节目时，我尝试整理了一份政府正在保密的所有新事物的清单。名单实在太长了，我甚至不知道是否已经全部搜罗齐全。准备好了吗？副总统正陷入一场诉讼，争论他是否必须公布他在制定能源政策时会见的人员名单。有一项行政命令允许前总统将更多的旧文件列为机密。还有布什政府的官方政策：如果法律允许，就绝不根据《信息自由法》发布任何文件。国会的委员会主席们——请注意，这些人是共和党人，是共和党人——正在公开抱怨他们无法从行政部门、从他们本应监督的机构获取信息。
And all this stuff is before you get the stuff that has to do with the War on Terror. Add that, and you've got the federal government pulling information from its own websites and removing its documents from public libraries. There are the secret trials and deportations of suspected terrorists. To people being held without any charges at all in military brigs, as many as 400 people being held as material witnesses because the government wants to get information out of them. The new kinds of wiretaps that have been authorized. There is the Total Information Awareness Program, in its pilot stage, which will be able to monitor all of our credit card and bank transactions, our phone calls, our email, our medical records. The part of government that is secret is growing.
而所有这些，还仅仅是在涉及反恐战争的内容之前。加上这些，你就会发现联邦政府正在从其官方网站上撤下信息，并从公共图书馆移除文件。还有对恐怖嫌疑人的秘密审判和驱逐出境。以及那些被关押在军事监狱中、没有任何指控的人，多达400人因被视为重要证人而受到关押，因为政府想从他们口中获取信息。还有授权使用的新型窃听手段。“全面信息意识计划”正处于试点阶段，它将能够监控我们所有的信用卡和银行交易、电话、电子邮件和医疗记录。政府中保密的部分正在不断扩大。
And so we thought today we would step back, take a look at exactly how far it's gone. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life , distributed by Public Radio International. Today on our program, The Secret Government, A Beginner's Guide. Our program today in three acts. Act One is about disappeared persons, American citizens held without charges. Act Two is about people thrown out of the country after secret trials. Act Three is about a secret court made of conservative judges that got so upset about what the current Justice Department was doing in secret that for the first time in the court's history it broke its veil of secrecy and went public. Stay with us.
所以我们今天想退一步，看看这一切到底发展到了什么地步。这里是芝加哥WBEZ电台播出的《美国生活》，由公共广播国际公司发行。今天我们的节目主题是《秘密政府：初学者指南》。今天的节目分为三幕。第一幕关于“失踪者”，即那些未经指控被关押的美国公民。第二幕关于秘密审判后被逐出境的人。第三幕关于一个由保守派法官组成的秘密法庭，他们对现任司法部秘密行事的做法感到如此愤怒，以至于在法庭历史上首次打破了保密的面纱，公开了此事。请继续收听。
Act One, Until the End of the War. There are at least two American citizens being held without charges, unable to see lawyers, in military jails in the United States. There could actually be more. Jack Hitt tried to find out everything he could about one of these guys, who you may remember from the news a while back, Jose Padilla.
第一幕：《直到战争结束》。目前至少有两名美国公民在未经指控的情况下，被关押在美国的军事监狱中，无法会见律师。实际上可能还有更多。杰克·希特试图查明他能了解到的关于其中一个人的所有信息，你可能在不久前的新闻中听说过他，那个人就是何塞·帕迪利亚。
Here's the way most of us remember it, if we remember it at all. A Monday morning last June, all the major networks broke from their programming to go to a live satellite broadcast by Attorney General John Ashcroft, from Moscow of all places. Here's CNN.
如果我们还有印象的话，大部分人对这件事的记忆是这样的：去年6月的一个周一早晨，所有主流电视网都中断了节目，转而直播司法部长约翰·阿什克罗夫特从莫斯科发出的卫星信号——竟然是在莫斯科。以下是CNN的报道。
Ethan, I'm sorry. I need to interrupt you there. We do have some breaking news and we need to go to Moscow. This is Attorney General John Ashcroft talking about a terrorist capture.
伊桑，抱歉。我需要打断你一下。我们有一些突发新闻，必须转往莫斯科。这是司法部长约翰·阿什克罗夫特关于逮捕一名恐怖分子的讲话。
--United States in his capacity as commander-in-chief determined that Abdullah al-Mujahir, born Jose Padilla, is an enemy combatant. In apprehending al-Mujahir as he sought entry into the United States, we have disrupted an unfolding terrorist plot to attack the United States by exploding a radioactive dirty bomb.
……美国政府以三军统帅的身份认定，阿卜杜拉·穆哈吉尔（出生名为何塞·帕迪利亚）为敌方战斗人员。在逮捕寻求入境美国的穆哈吉尔时，我们挫败了一项正在策划的、通过引爆放射性脏弹袭击美国的恐怖阴谋。
And then, an hour after that press conference, the administration launched a series of other press conferences. Right away, they were backing off Ashcroft's spine-tingling sense of alarm. Paul Wolfowitz from the Pentagon said it probably wasn't a plot, just some, quote, "loose talk." And here's what FBI director Robert Mueller had to say about it.
在那次新闻发布会一小时后，政府又发起了一系列其他新闻发布会。他们很快就开始收回阿什克罗夫特那番令人毛骨悚然的警示。五角大楼的保罗·沃尔福威茨说，这可能根本不是阴谋，只是某种“随口乱说”。以下是联邦调查局局长罗伯特·穆勒对此的评论。
It had not gone, as far as we know, much past the discussion stage. But there were substantial discussions undertaken.
据我们所知，事情并没有进展到超出讨论阶段的程度。但确实进行了实质性的讨论。
The timing of all this was curious, because they'd actually nabbed Padilla a month before, but chose to announce it on a day when Washington was reeling over FBI whistleblower Colleen Rowley. It pushed her off the front pages. You remember Rowley. She was testifying in Congress about all the FBI bungling and miscommunication that made us miss the clues pointing to 9/11. More than a few people noticed that the Padilla announcement applied a certain emphasis on bureaucratic efficiency and inter-agency cooperation.
这一切的时机非常令人好奇，因为他们实际上在一个月前就逮捕了帕迪利亚，却选择在华盛顿因FBI举报人科琳·罗利而陷入混乱的那一天宣布。这把她挤出了头条。你还记得罗利吧。她当时正在国会作证，揭露FBI所有的失职和沟通失误，导致我们错过了指向911事件的线索。不少人注意到，帕迪利亚的公告刻意强调了官僚效率和跨部门协作。
Because of the close cooperation among the FBI, the CIA, the Defense Department, and other federal agencies--
由于联邦调查局、中央情报局、国防部和其他联邦机构之间的密切合作——
--was a result of the close cooperative work of FBI agents and CIA agents here and--
——是联邦调查局特工和中央情报局特工在此处密切合作的结果，并且——
--demonstrates the successful sharing of information and close cooperation among US government agencies that will be key to winning the war against terrorism.
——证明了美国政府机构之间成功的信息共享和密切合作，这将是赢得反恐战争的关键。
The administration was furious with anyone who noticed these coincidences. Here's a White House press conference just after the Padilla story broke.
对于任何注意到这些巧合的人，政府都感到非常愤怒。以下是帕迪利亚的故事曝光后不久，白宫举行的一次新闻发布会。
How do you now respond to critics who are trying to draw a link, fair or unfair, between the announcement of that arrest to the intelligence [UNINTELLIGIBLE]?
你现在如何回应那些试图将此次逮捕公告与情报[听不清]联系起来的批评者，无论这种说法公正与否？
Look, these very few people who want to make such an outlandish political accusation represent the most cynical among the most partisan. And they're not to be taken seriously.
听着，这些极少数想要做出这种离奇政治指控的人，代表了党派人士中最愤世嫉俗的一群。他们不值得被认真对待。
In the days afterwards, we learned a little of Padilla's life. His rap sheet as a gang member in Chicago. His involvement in a murder-- it was a gun charge in Florida. He worked at a Fort Lauderdale Taco Bell, where he converted to Islam. Later he traveled to Pakistan and Afghanistan. There, according to two Al-Qaeda informants, he met with terrorist leaders and learned about dirty bombs.
在随后的日子里，我们了解了一些帕迪利亚的生平。他曾是芝加哥黑帮成员，有犯罪记录。他曾卷入一起谋杀案——在佛罗里达因枪支指控被捕。他在劳德代尔堡的一家塔可钟工作，在那里皈依了伊斯兰教。后来他前往巴基斯坦和阿富汗。根据两名基地组织线人的说法，他在那里会见了恐怖组织领导人，并学习了关于脏弹的知识。
In one court filing, the government admitted that their prime source on Padilla, Al-Qaeda leader Abu Zubaydah, had frequently fooled them with false information. The other informant, the government said, had recanted part of his testimony. With that hovering in the air, the story disappeared, and with it Padilla-- literally. The government did something to him it has never done to anyone. They transferred him from a civilian jail to a military brig outside Charleston, South Carolina. They refused to let him see a lawyer and they never charged him with anything. His own mother can't visit him. He will stay in his cell with the lights burning 24 hours a day, according to Ari Fleischer, quote, "for the duration of the war."
在一份法庭文件中，政府承认他们关于帕迪利亚的主要消息来源——基地组织领导人阿布·祖拜达——经常以虚假信息戏弄他们。政府称，另一名线人已撤回了部分证词。随着这些阴影笼罩，这个故事消失了，帕迪利亚也随之消失——字面意义上的消失。政府对他做了一件他们从未对任何人做过的事。他们将他从民事监狱转移到了南卡罗来纳州查尔斯顿外的一个军事监狱。他们拒绝让他见律师，也从未对他提出过任何指控。他自己的母亲都不能去探视他。据阿里·弗莱舍说，他将留在灯光24小时长明的牢房里，“直至战争结束”。
This was achieved by redefining Padilla with a new term that everyone heard for the first time that Monday morning.
这是通过用一个周一早晨大家第一次听到的新词重新定义帕迪利亚来实现的。
He is being detained under the laws of war as an enemy combatant.
他正作为敌方战斗人员，根据战争法受到拘留。
Enemy combatant. The rules of war talk about "unlawful combatants," but that term applies to soldiers caught on the field of battle. Enemy combatants can be American citizens seized in America and held without a lawyer or charges, or without much explanation from the government itself. If you try to get the Justice Department to talk about Padilla, here's what they say.
敌方战斗人员。战争规则谈到了“非法战斗人员”，但该术语适用于战场上被捕的士兵。敌方战斗人员可以是那些在美国领土上被抓获的美国公民，在没有律师或指控的情况下被关押，政府甚至不给出太多解释。如果你试图让司法部谈论帕迪利亚，他们会这么说。
We're not doing any on-the-record interviews in connection with Padilla.
关于帕迪利亚，我们不接受任何正式采访。
They wouldn't do an off-the-record interview about him either, and on the rare occasions when officials have had to talk about it in public, here's the sort of thing you get. This question was asked at the joint press conference, of Larry Thompson from the Justice Department.
他们甚至拒绝进行非正式采访，而在官员们偶尔不得不在公开场合谈论此事时，你会得到这样的回答。这个问题是在联合新闻发布会上提出来的，针对的是司法部的拉里·汤普森。
Beverly?
贝弗利？
Does he have legal representation at the moment?
他目前是否有法律代表？
He was being held under the authority of a federal judge. And he had legal representation in connection with that, yes.
他是在联邦法官的授权下被拘留的。关于这一点，他确实有法律代表，是的。
Does he now? Does he now?
他现在有吗？他现在有吗？
Larry, how far did they get--
拉里，他们进展到什么程度——
Does he now, she's asking. Does he have legal representation now? Thompson ignores her, takes one more question, and then ends the press conference. The answer to the question, of course, is no. Padilla lost his lawyer only a few hours before this press conference, when he was redefined as an enemy combatant.
她问的是他现在有吗。他现在有法律代表吗？汤普森无视了她，又接受了另一个问题，然后结束了新闻发布会。当然，这个问题的答案是：没有。帕迪利亚的律师在这次新闻发布会前几个小时就被解除了关系，因为他被重新定义为敌方战斗人员。
A word now about that lawyer. For the month prior to the Ashcroft press conference, Padilla had been held in jail as a possible material witness for some kind of crime. We don't know what it was. For the indigent, though, there's a round robin of good working lawyers who donate their time. For Padilla, the wheel spun and turned up a defense lawyer who hangs her shingle across the street from the courthouse in Jersey City, New Jersey. Located just above a bail bondsman office, it's a two-woman shop-- a secretary named Angela and a lawyer, Donna Newman.
现在说一下那位律师。在阿什克罗夫特新闻发布会之前的一个月里，帕迪利亚一直作为某种罪行的“重要证人”被关押在监狱里。我们不知道具体是什么罪行。然而，对于贫困者，有一个轮流担任、贡献时间的优秀律师库。对于帕迪利亚，轮到了一个在新泽西州泽西市法院对面挂牌执业的辩护律师。那是一家位于保释担保人办公室楼上的双人小店——一名叫安吉拉的秘书和一名律师唐娜·纽曼。
Newman works the standard criminal defense beat-- fraud, money laundering, mobsters, drugs. Not the sort of lawyer who usually ends up suing the Attorney General, Secretary of Defense, and the President of the United States.
纽曼处理的是标准的刑事辩护工作——欺诈、洗钱、黑帮、毒品。她并不是那种通常会起诉美国司法部长、国防部长和美国总统的律师。
I don't think so. I don't know. They'd be surprised. I did well in law school, a good student, but I certainly would not have been the one they would have chosen. I'm certainly not a radical. And it's a joke to think I am, because that's how unradical I am. I'm very conservative in my lifestyle, in my children. I'm older. I have grown children. I didn't even picket in the '60s.
我不这么认为。我不知道。他们会感到惊讶的。我在法学院表现很好，是个好学生，但我绝对不会是他们会选择的那种人。我绝对不是激进分子。认为我是激进分子简直是个笑话，因为我一点都不激进。我的生活方式、对孩子的教养都非常保守。我年纪大了。我有已经成年的孩子。我甚至在60年代都没有参加过游行。
When Newman first got the case, it was like dozens she'd seen. File a bunch of papers contesting the warrant, seeking bail-- routine stuff. And the judge sets a hearing date, in this case June 11. June 11 was also the day John Ashcroft broke into regular television programming around 10:00 AM with his Moscow conference about Padilla. Not everybody was in front of a TV to hear, people like Padilla's lawyer, Donna Newman.
当纽曼最初接到这个案子时，这就像她处理过的几十个案子一样。提交一堆文件抗辩搜查令、申请保释——例行公事。法官设定了听证日期，在这个案子里是6月11日。6月11日也是约翰·阿什克罗夫特在上午10点左右通过莫斯科会议打断常规电视节目发布帕迪利亚消息的日子。并不是每个人都在电视前收听，比如帕迪利亚的律师唐娜·纽曼。
I'm in my car and I'm going to court. I hadn't had the radio on. And I receive a call on my cellphone from the assistant United States attorney. And he advised me that my client was taken by the military to a naval brig. I thought he was kidding. Needless to say, if you're hearing this and you hadn't listened to the radio, you would also think that this was a joke. Ashcroft-- I mean, giving this statement, it's just like, what are you talking about?
我当时在车里去法院的路上。我没开收音机。我接到了美国联邦检察官助理打来的手机电话。他通知我，我的客户被军方带走送往了海军监狱。我以为他在开玩笑。不用说，如果你听到这个消息，而之前没听广播，你也会认为这是个玩笑。阿什克罗夫特——我的意思是，发表这个声明，简直是，你在说什么啊？
To explain what happens next, I have to talk about something so basic, a principle that's so ingrained in what this country is, that most of us don't even know it exists-- habeas corpus. We've all heard that phrase, although let's be honest, we don't quite know what it means.
为了解释接下来发生的事情，我必须谈论一件非常基础的事情，一个深植于这个国家本质的原则，以至于我们大多数人甚至不知道它的存在——人身保护令。我们都听过这个词，尽管诚实地说，我们并不完全明白它的含义。
Actually, it's the most fundamental routine of all Western law. It's 700 years old. Its meaning in Latin, "you hold the body," sounds like a challenge, and it is. At every criminal arrest, it orders the government to show the body-- in other words, show me the guy you're holding, so I can see he's OK, and second, tell us the charge against him. Known as "the great writ of liberty," its suspension was, along with unfair taxation, the primary reason for the American Revolution.
实际上，它是所有西方法律中最根本的常规。它已经有700年的历史了。它在拉丁语中的含义是“你持有躯体”，听起来像是一种挑战，确实如此。在每次刑事逮捕中，它都命令政府“交出躯体”——换句话说，带出你拘留的那个人，让我看看他是否安好；其次，告知我们针对他的指控。它被称为“伟大的自由令状”，它的暂停与不公正的税收一起，是美国革命的主要原因。
The founding fathers enshrined habeas in Article I of our Constitution, declaring it could be suspended only during, quote, "rebellion or invasion." When a government starts tossing out things as foundational as habeas, the proceedings quickly grow strange. Soon after the Ashcroft press conference, Newman went to court to find out what happened to her client. She was told she no longer had a client, because her client no longer had a lawyer. But Newman wouldn't hear it. She kept on filing motions as if the old routines of the law were still in place. That said, she was in uncharted terrain, and the problems she encountered were often surreal.
开国元勋们在宪法第一条中将人身保护令奉为神圣，声明它只能在“叛乱或入侵”期间被暂停。当政府开始抛弃像人身保护令这样基础的东西时，诉讼程序很快就会变得奇怪起来。在阿什克罗夫特新闻发布会后不久，纽曼去法院查明她的客户发生了什么事。她被告知她不再有客户，因为她的客户不再有律师。但纽曼不肯罢休。她继续提交动议，仿佛旧有的法律常规依然有效。话虽如此，她当时正处于未知的领域，她遇到的问题往往非常超现实。
For habeas to be filed, the petitioner-- in this case, Mr. Padilla-- has to sign it. They have the audacity to complain that he can't sign it. So it's not a valid petition because he can't sign it. Well, of course, you're the one who took him away. So that's mind-boggling, that they make that argument.
为了提交人身保护令，请愿人——在本案中是帕迪利亚先生——必须签署。他们竟厚颜无耻地抱怨说他无法签署。所以这是一份无效的请愿书，因为他不能签字。好吧，当然，因为你就是那个把他带走的人。所以他们提出这种论点真是令人匪夷所思。
They said, in the beginning of one of their briefs, that we did not dispute his enemy combatant status or the facts leading up to the government's declaration. Well, that's another Catch-22. How can I dispute it? Can I meet with my client? So you're saying I concede this because you've made it so that I can't meet with him.
他们在其中一份简报的开头说，我们不质疑他的敌方战斗人员身份，也不质疑导致政府宣布该身份的事实。好吧，这是另一个“第22条军规”。我怎么能质疑它？我能见我的客户吗？所以你们是在说我承认了这一点，因为你们让我无法与他见面。
And I wonder, who is writing the brief? Aren't they embarrassed to write that? I mean, I couldn't write that. I would be going, what is the judge going think of me by my writing that? Because it's so clear. Well, of course she can't hand in an affidavit. He's not around, remember? You're the one who took him away.
我真想知道，是谁在写那份简报？他们写的时候不觉得尴尬吗？我的意思是，我写不出那种东西。我会想，法官会因为我写这些而怎么看我？因为它太明显了。当然她无法提交宣誓书。他不在身边，还记得吗？你就是那个把他带走的人。
The government did cite legal precedent for its right to hold Padilla, specifically two cases.
政府确实引用了法律先例来证明其拘留帕迪利亚的权利，具体是两个案件。
There's clear Supreme Court and circuit court authority for such a detention.
最高法院和巡回法院有明确的权威支持此类拘留。
What is the Supreme Court  precedent?
最高法院的先例是什么？
It's a 1942 case, Ex parte Quirin. And there's a 9th Circuit case, and I forgot the name of it. It's In re Territo. It's a 1946 case.
那是1942年的“奎林案”（Ex parte Quirin）。还有一个第九巡回法院的案件，我忘了名字了。是“特雷托案”（In re Territo）。那是1946年的案件。
Let's talk about those cases. The Territo case involved a man who was born an American citizen but who grew up in Italy. He was captured on the battlefield in World War II, fighting on the side of fascist Italy. Unlike Padilla, he was charged, given a lawyer and a trial. The Quirin case involved eight Nazis, including one American citizen, who actually landed on Long Island in 1942 with plans to blow up US factories. They were all given lawyers and had trials, even though the war was on.
让我们谈谈这些案件。“特雷托案”涉及一名出生于美国的公民，但在意大利长大。他在二战战场上被俘，当时他在为法西斯意大利一方作战。与帕迪利亚不同，他受到了指控，并被给予了律师和审判。“奎林案”涉及八名纳粹分子，其中包括一名美国公民，他们于1942年实际登陆长岛，计划炸毁美国工厂。他们都得到了律师并接受了审判，尽管当时战争正在进行。
The only question in both cases was what kind of proceeding, in a civilian court or a military tribunal? There was no question that they'd get lawyers and trials.
两个案件中唯一的问题是采取什么样的程序，是在民事法庭还是军事法庭？毫无疑问，他们都能得到律师和审判。
We do have Mr. Padilla, or Mr. al-Mujahir as he called himself more recently, in military custody.
我们确实把帕迪利亚先生，或者他最近自称的穆哈吉尔先生，关押在军事监护之下。
Even though the Justice Department won't speak on the record to journalists, there have been rare occasions where certain officials have tried to explain what has happened. Here's assistant Attorney General Michael Chertoff at a public forum at the New York University law school. He says the question raised by the Padilla case is this one.
尽管司法部不会向记者发表正式评论，但确实有极少数官员试图解释所发生的事情。以下是司法部助理部长迈克尔·切尔托夫在纽约大学法学院的一次公开论坛上的讲话。他说帕迪利亚案提出的问题是这个。
--the issue of, what do you do when you apprehend people in the field of battle? Let me go back to World War II. We captured a lot of Germans and Japanese and Italians in the battlefield in the course of the war. Those people didn't get lawyers. Do we really think, in the battlefield, that we should lawyer up everybody who's captured?
——关于当你从战场上逮捕人时该怎么办的问题？让我回到二战。我们在战争期间在战场上俘虏了大量德国人、日本人和意大利人。这些人没有得到律师。难道我们真的认为，在战场上，我们应该为每一个被俘虏的人都安排律师吗？
Chertoff takes for granted the assumption that since planes flew into buildings on 9/11, everywhere in America is now a battlefield. And on some level, we all know there's some truth in this. But still, there are distinctions. No one is talking about providing lawyers to the Al-Qaeda terrorists in Guantanamo. They're prisoners of war captured in Afghanistan. Padilla is an American citizen seized in Chicago. And then there's that phrase he used, "lawyer up," as if this involves someone who spilled hot coffee on her lap at McDonald's, and not the suspension of habeas corpus that dates back 700 years and is one of the core principles of our Constitution.
切尔托夫理所当然地认为，既然飞机在911事件中撞毁了大楼，那么美国任何地方现在都是战场。从某种层面来说，我们都知道这确实有一些事实依据。但即便如此，还是有区别的。没人谈论为关塔那摩的基地组织恐怖分子提供律师。他们是在阿富汗俘虏的战俘。帕迪利亚是在芝加哥被抓获的美国公民。此外，他还使用了“安排律师”（lawyer up）这种说法，好像这涉及的是某人在麦当劳膝盖上溅了热咖啡的民事纠纷，而不是暂停已有700年历史、作为我们宪法核心原则之一的人身保护令。
America was founded on the proposition that when we get in trouble, we get lawyered up. And part of what's so confusing about Padilla is that so many other defendants have been lawyered up. Remember John Walker Lindh, the so-called American Taliban? He was actually captured on the field of battle in Afghanistan. Now that's an enemy combatant. He got lawyered up. The Buffalo Six, those young Muslims who slipped into Afghanistan and then came back to America? Arrested and lawyered up. How about Zacarias Moussaoui? He's not even an American. He's a French Moroccan, and was allegedly the 20th guy on September 11. Lawyered up. In the end, it may be that the real reason Padilla has been refused a lawyer is not the alarming evidence against him, but the opposite.
美国建立在这样一个命题之上：当我们遇到麻烦时，我们可以请律师。帕迪利亚案之所以令人如此困惑，是因为有这么多其他被告都请了律师。还记得约翰·沃克·林德（John Walker Lindh）那个所谓的“美国塔利班”吗？他确实是在阿富汗战场上被俘虏的。那才是一个典型的敌方战斗人员。他请了律师。“布法罗六人组”（Buffalo Six），那些潜入阿富汗后来又回到美国的年轻穆斯林？被捕并请了律师。那扎卡里亚斯·穆萨维（Zacarias Moussaoui）呢？他甚至不是美国人。他是法国摩洛哥人，据称是911事件中的第20名劫机者。也请了律师。最终，帕迪利亚被拒绝给予律师的真正原因可能并不是因为针对他的证据多么令人震惊，而恰恰相反。
They have less evidence against Mr. Padilla, so they can't bring charges. See, they don't have probable cause to bring a charge. They certainly couldn't prove a charge. So their solution, which is really frightening, is if we can't prove a case, we simply get rid of the individual. We simply lock them up. And that just turns our criminal justice system upside-down.
他们针对帕迪利亚先生的证据较少，所以他们无法提出指控。看，他们没有充分的理由提出指控。他们肯定无法证实指控。所以他们的解决方案，也就是真正可怕的地方在于，如果我们无法证明案件，我们就简单地除掉这个人。我们简单地把他锁起来。这彻底颠倒了我们的刑事司法体系。
Warning. Restricted area. Keep out. Authorized personnel only. Man, this thing is huge.
警告。限制区域。禁止进入。仅限授权人员。天哪，这地方真大。
Over the Christmas holiday, I was in Charleston, South Carolina, visiting my mom. One morning, my nephew and I drove over to the Navy facility where the government's holding Padilla. I got turned away, of course, told that the closest I could get was the fence, so I pulled over. Behind the barbed wire was, strangely, nothing more than acres and acres of low-country pine forest, the kind I grew up in. Deep in it, somewhere, was the brig and Jose Padilla.
圣诞假期期间，我在南卡罗来纳州查尔斯顿探望母亲。一天早上，我和侄子开车去了政府关押帕迪利亚的海军设施。当然，我被拒之门外，被告知我能到达最近的地方就是围栏，所以我把车停在路边。铁丝网后面，奇怪的是，除了大片大片的低地松树林外，什么也没有，那种我从小就熟悉的环境。在深处某处，就是那个监狱和何塞·帕迪利亚。
Just before this, the New York Judge who was hearing Donna Newman's motions, Michael Mukasey, issued his ruling. It was a Solomonic one. He said Padilla could finally meet with his lawyer to challenge his status as an enemy combatant. But he also said President Bush had the power to declare American citizens on home soil to be enemy combatants. Finally, he also said the court should oversee it all.
在此之前不久，负责审理唐娜·纽曼动议的纽约法官迈克尔·穆卡西发布了他的裁决。这是一个“所罗门式”的裁决。他说帕迪利亚终于可以会见他的律师，以挑战他作为敌方战斗人员的身份。但他同时也说布什总统有权宣布本土的美国公民为敌方战斗人员。最后，他还说法院应该监督整个过程。
The tone of Mukasey's opinion is nervous. He's nervous. At one point he opines about the kind of case, quote, "a judge is unqualified for but must decide." And if you read all those old opinions, like the World War II cases, all the judges write in the same nervous tone. They don't toss off habeas very easily. Supreme Court Justice Felix Frankfurter, who supported the Quirin decision when it came down, groaned later, "It's not a happy precedent."
穆卡西意见书的基调很紧张。他很紧张。在某一处，他感叹道，这类案件“是法官缺乏资格但必须判决的”。如果你阅读所有那些旧的判决，比如二战时期的案件，所有法官写的基调都是一样的紧张。他们不会轻易抛弃人身保护令。最高法院大法官费利克斯·法兰克福特在奎林案裁决下达时支持了该决定，但后来感叹道：“这不是一个令人愉快的先例。”
In comparison, the Bush administration is not agonizing about suspending this basic right, at least not publicly. While in the Persian Gulf, Secretary of Defense Donald Rumsfeld complained about folks who are concerned with Padilla's right to see a lawyer. Quote, "Our normal procedure is that if somebody does something unlawful, that the first thing we want to do is apprehend them, then try them in a court, and then punish them. In this case, that is not our first interest. Our interest, really, in this case is not law enforcement. It's not punishment. Our interest at the moment is to try to find out everything he knows."
相比之下，布什政府对于暂停这一基本权利并没有感到苦恼，至少在公开场合没有。在波斯湾，国防部长唐纳德·拉姆斯菲尔德抱怨那些关心帕迪利亚会见律师权利的人。他说：“我们的正常程序是，如果有人做了非法的事，我们首先要做的是逮捕他们，然后在法庭上审判他们，然后惩罚他们。在这种情况下，这不是我们的首要利益。我们在此案中的利益真的不在于执法。不在于惩罚。我们目前的利益是设法查出他所知道的一切。”
Maybe Donald Rumsfeld is right, that the War on Terror is so important that we do need to lock people up without charges for the duration of the war just to find out what they know. Maybe it's true that the new battlefield is not just in Afghanistan but extends everywhere and anywhere on our own soil. Maybe it's true that even though in every previous war the courts have permitted some kind of trial, this war is different.
也许唐纳德·拉姆斯菲尔德是对的，反恐战争如此重要，以至于我们确实需要将人关押起来而不进行指控，直到战争结束，只为了查明他们所知道的一切。也许确实新的战场不仅仅在阿富汗，而是延伸到了我们本土的任何地方。也许确实，尽管在之前的所有战争中法院都允许进行某种审判，但这场战争是不同的。
And maybe it's true that we have to trust the government when it says, the secret evidence against these Americans can't be revealed in a court of law. Maybe we need to be rethinking our basic Constitutional rights. But if so, it's not to be done lightly, not to be done off the record. We should, as a people, talk about all this and agree on it first.
也许确实，当政府说针对这些美国人的秘密证据不能在法庭上公开时，我们必须信任它。也许我们需要重新思考我们的基本宪法权利。但如果是这样，也不应该轻率地去做，不应该在不公开的情况下去做。我们应该作为人民，先谈论所有这一切并达成共识。
This week, The Wall Street Journal reported that the government is preparing to declare some more American citizens here at home to be enemy combatants and remove them to military bases. So start talking.
本周，《华尔街日报》报道称，政府正准备宣布更多国内的美国公民为敌方战斗人员，并将他们移送到军事基地。所以，开始讨论吧。
Jack Hitt in New Haven.
在纽黑文报道的杰克·希特。
One quick footnote to that story, before you start talking. Late this week, the government went to the judge in Jose Padilla's case and asked the judge to consider changing his recent decision about Padilla, specifically his decision to let Donna Newman meet and confer with Padilla as lawyer and client. The reason the government gives for this? They're interrogating him, they say. And the government says that if he sees a lawyer and has any hope of getting out any time soon, he won't give any information in the interrogation.
在你们开始讨论之前，那个故事还有一个简短的脚注。本周晚些时候，政府去法院找负责何塞·帕迪利亚案的法官，要求法官考虑更改他最近关于帕迪利亚的决定，特别是他允许唐娜·纽曼作为律师与帕迪利亚会面和商议的决定。政府给出的理由是？他们说，他们正在审讯他。政府说，如果他见到律师并有任何在短期内获释的希望，他就不会在审讯中提供任何信息。
OK. You have one minute to start talking. Coming up, a sneaky way to get some answers about secret deportations. That's in one Chicago minute from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International, when our program continues.
好的。你们有一分钟时间开始讨论。接下来，一种获取关于秘密驱逐出境答案的狡猾方法。那将在芝加哥公共广播电台和公共广播国际公司的《芝加哥一分钟》之后，节目继续时播出。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose some theme, and bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show, The Secret Government, a beginner's guide to all the new secrecy in our country. We've arrived at Act Two of our program. Act Two, Secret Trials and Secret Deportations.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们都会选择一个主题，并为您带来关于该主题的各种不同故事。今天的节目，《秘密政府：关于我国所有新保密措施的初学者指南》。我们已经来到了节目的第二幕。第二幕：秘密审判和秘密驱逐。
In the current war, the War on Terror, the government has been rounding up foreigners, checking their immigration status, and then sometimes deporting them. David Kestenbaum tried to find out everything that can be found out about who they are and what happened to them once they were arrested and put on trial in secret.
在当前的战争，即反恐战争中，政府一直在搜捕外国人，检查他们的移民身份，然后有时会将他们驱逐出境。大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆试图查明关于他们是谁，以及他们在被逮捕并秘密受审后发生了什么的所有可查信息。
In the months after September 11, the US government rounded up over 700 immigrants, 700 people, and refused to talk about them, even in court. Civil rights groups sued to get the names, and as part of the filings, here's how far things have gone. The government submitted a 118-page list of people who had been detained, their names, one by one, inked out with a black marker.
在911事件后的几个月里，美国政府搜捕了超过700名移民，700人，并拒绝谈论他们，甚至在法庭上也拒绝谈论。民权组织起诉以获取这些名字，作为提交的文件的一部分，事情的发展程度如下。政府提交了一份118页的被拘留者名单，他们的名字一个接一个地被黑墨水涂掉了。
[DIAL TONE] Good morning. Public Affairs.
[拨号音] 早上好。公共事务部。
Today, the Department of Justice will only talk round numbers. You're about to hear just about everything the government has to say on the subject. I talked with Jorge Martinez, a spokesperson for the DOJ.
今天，司法部只会谈论大约的数字。你即将听到政府关于这个主题能说的几乎所有内容。我采访了司法部发言人豪尔赫·马丁内斯。
Can you tell me how many people were detained on immigration charges in the sweep after September 11?
你能告诉我911事件后的搜捕行动中有多少人因移民指控被拘留吗？
765.
765人。
How many people ended up being deported?
最终有多少人被驱逐出境？
478 people have been deported to date.
迄今为止已有478人被驱逐出境。
Do you have any sense for how many of them had ties to terrorism?
你是否了解他们中有多少人与恐怖主义有联系？
We don't, and because it is classified and sensitive information, I am precluded by our regulations from talking about it.
我们不知道，而且因为这是机密和敏感信息，根据我们的规定，我被禁止谈论它。
What if I have the names of some of the people? Can you then discuss their cases with me?
如果我有其中一些人的名字呢？那么你可以和我讨论他们的案子吗？
No, unfortunately, I can't, again, because it is part of an ongoing investigation. And I am precluded from talking about it.
不，不幸的是，我不能，再次强调，因为它是正在进行的调查的一部分。我被禁止谈论它。
And there are six people still in custody?
还有六个人仍被关押吗？
Yes.
是的。
Can you tell me anything about them?
你能告诉我关于他们的任何信息吗？
No, unfortunately, I can't.
不，不幸的是，我不能。
What is the government hiding? If you want to know who was deported, why they were fingered in the investigation, how long they were held, did they get a fair trial, did they get to make a phone call, you have to try somewhere besides Washington, D.C.
政府在隐瞒什么？如果你想知道谁被驱逐了，他们为什么在调查中被盯上，他们被关押了多久，他们是否得到了公平审判，他们是否被允许打一个电话，你必须去华盛顿特区以外的地方寻找答案。
Good evening, ladies and gentlemen, and a warm welcome on board our Swiss flight bound for Karachi.
各位女士、各位先生，晚上好，欢迎乘坐瑞士航空飞往卡拉奇的航班。
Swissair Flight 246 to Pakistan. Coach class, unwatchable movie starring Robin Williams. Our mission: to meet some of the 400 people who got kicked out and find out what happened. Let me say up front that the people you're going to hear were tracked down by the American Civil Liberties Union, which thinks the government behaved very badly here. Emily Whitfield from the ACLU is also on the plane. She's sitting up in business class.
瑞士航空246号航班飞往巴基斯坦。经济舱，播放着罗宾·威廉姆斯主演的无聊电影。我们的任务：会见那400名被驱逐者中的一些人，找出发生了什么。我事先说明，你们将要听到的人是由美国公民自由联盟（ACLU）追踪到的，该组织认为政府在此事上表现非常糟糕。来自ACLU的艾米丽·惠特菲尔德也在飞机上。她坐在商务舱。
When the feds wouldn't release the names, the ACLU did something clever. It did an end-run around our government and wrote letters to foreign embassies requesting the names of deportees, letters to the countries where the people had been sent back to.
当联邦政府拒绝公布名字时，ACLU做了一件聪明的事。它绕过了我们的政府，致信外国大使馆索取被驱逐者的名单，致信那些人们被遣返回去的国家。
United Arab Emirates, Pakistan, India, et cetera. And we heard back from some of them, just a polite "thanks for getting in touch." But the Pakistan consulate called us back. And they said, oh, yeah, we have a list. And we said, do you, now? Can we see it? And they said, sure. And that was extraordinary, because another country was giving us something our own government would not give to us.
阿拉伯联合酋长国、巴基斯坦、印度等等。我们收到了一些人的回复，只是一些礼貌的“感谢联系”。但巴基斯坦领事馆回电了。他们说，哦，是的，我们有一份名单。我们说，你们现在有了吗？我们可以看看吗？他们说，当然。这太不同寻常了，因为另一个国家给了我们本国政府不愿给我们的东西。
The plane takes a weird turn to fly around Iraq, and lands in Karachi, Pakistan. This is where Daniel Pearl was kidnapped and decapitated. Bin Laden himself may be hiding in Pakistan. I think about this, getting off the plane. To find out what the Justice Department is hiding, I've gone somewhere the State Department warns not to. Non-emergency personnel at the embassy here have been ordered to leave.
飞机绕飞伊拉克，降落在巴基斯坦卡拉奇。这就是丹尼尔·珀尔被绑架并斩首的地方。拉登本人可能正藏在巴基斯坦。我思考着这一点，走下飞机。为了找出司法部在隐瞒什么，我来到了国务院警告不要去的地方。这里大使馆的非紧急人员已被命令离开。
Over the course of a week, I visit a handful of people who have been deported from the United States. Here's the deal. The Pakistani embassy's list had over 100 people on it. The ACLU, with the help of a Pakistani civil rights group, tracked down about 35 of those. 19 were willing to talk to the press. Of these, the ACLU people set up interviews with five whose cases they thought were compelling. And yes, in some instances, the US government seems to have behaved in ways I think many Americans would think was pretty unfair. But I have to say, other times things didn't seem so bad, even in these hand-picked cases. But you can judge for yourself. Also there was one nagging question every deportee had. I'll get to that later.
在一周的时间里，我拜访了几个被从美国驱逐出境的人。情况是这样的。巴基斯坦大使馆的名单上有100多人。ACLU在巴基斯坦民权组织的帮助下，追踪到了其中的约35人。19人愿意接受媒体采访。其中，ACLU的人安排了五人接受采访，他们认为这些人的案例很有说服力。是的，在某些情况下，美国政府的行为似乎以我认为许多美国人会认为非常不公平的方式行事。但我必须说，其他时候事情看起来没那么糟，即使在这些精选的案例中。但你们可以自己判断。此外，每个被驱逐者都有一个困扰他们的问题。我稍后再谈。
[SPEAKING URDU]
[乌尔都语对话]
The cab driver on the first day has a long white beard and says he was a big fan of the Taliban, but he seems perfectly nice. He stops to ask directions a few times and pulls into a dusty street where a man named Ansar Mahmood lives. Until recently, Ansar and his family lived 7,000 miles west of here in New Jersey.
第一天的出租车司机留着长长的白胡子，说他是塔利班的忠实粉丝，但他看起来非常和蔼。他停下来问了几次路，开进了一条尘土飞扬的街道，那是安萨尔·马哈茂德住的地方。直到最近，安萨尔和他的家人还住在西边7000英里外的纽约新泽西州。
Ansar's story begins like this. One morning, three weeks after the attacks on the World Trade Center, his doorbell rang. Ansar looked out the window and saw 25 or 30 FBI agents. He says he knew they were FBI because they had FBI on their jackets just like on TV. The FBI arrested him. His wife, Uzma, says that for 25 days, she had no idea at all where he was.
安萨尔的故事是这样开始的。一天早上，在世界贸易中心遇袭三周后，他家的门铃响了。安萨尔从窗户向外看，看到了25或30名联邦调查局特工。他说他知道他们是FBI，因为他们的夹克上写着FBI，就像电视上那样。FBI逮捕了他。他的妻子乌兹玛说，在25天里，她根本不知道他在哪里。
He just vanished, like that. They didn't give me any hint, where is he and where they take him and when he will come back, and this and that. He was just gone away from our life.
他就那样消失了。他们没有给我任何提示，他在哪里，他们把他带到了哪里，他什么时候会回来，等等。他就这样从我们的生活中消失了。
What about the kids?
孩子们呢？
Yes, they were very upset. They were very aggressive at the time, after some times that they were out of control. I cannot control them after four, five months. They wanted to kill everybody. They hit me twice.
是的，他们非常不安。他们当时非常有攻击性，过了一段时间他们失控了。四五个月后我无法控制他们。他们想杀掉所有人。他们打了我不止一次。
Here's what Ansar says happened to him. When the FBI came by, the agents asked if he knew anything about Osama Bin Laden. They also asked about Ansar's brother-in-law, who they suspected was involved in credit card fraud. Ansar says the FBI eventually took him into custody for a different reason, because he had overstayed his visa. This, he admits, is true. He was working in the country illegally, using a fake Social Security card.
以下是安萨尔说发生在他身上的事。当FBI来的时候，特工问他是否知道关于奥萨马·本·拉登的任何事。他们还问起安萨尔的姐夫，他们怀疑他涉及信用卡欺诈。安萨尔说，FBI最终以另一个理由拘留了他，因为他的签证逾期了。他承认这是事实。他持伪造的社会保障卡在该国非法工作。
They put him in a jail near the Brooklyn-Queens Expressway. He says he was told not to ask any questions or he would be killed, and he was placed in solitary confinement for four months.
他们把他关在布鲁克林-皇后区高速公路附近的一所监狱里。他说他被告知不要问任何问题，否则他会被杀，他被单独监禁了四个月。
The size of the cell is six feet wide and about 12 feet long. What I can see from the window-- I can see the sky. I can see the traffic. I can see the BQE. Or sometimes, they transfer us to a different cell-- I can see the Statue of Liberty too. In cells 19 to 25, you can see the Statue of Liberty from there.
牢房大小是6英尺宽，约12英尺长。我从窗户能看到什么——我能看到天空。我能看到交通。我能看到布鲁克林-皇后区高速公路。或者有时，他们把我们转移到不同的牢房——我也能看到自由女神像。在19到25号牢房，从那里可以看到自由女神像。
Those are sort of the good rooms.
那些算是很好的房间了。
Yeah, they are good rooms. Because at least you can see the sea. You can see the river and you can see the Statue of Liberty in front of you, which is the symbol of liberty of the United States.
是的，它们是好房间。因为至少你能看到海。你可以看到河，你可以看到面前的自由女神像，那是美国自由的象征。
After a month, jail personnel painted over the window, possibly for security reasons, possibly to avoid quotes like the one you just heard. Ansar says the cell became like a grave. Seven months after he was taken into custody, the INS took him out of jail and deported him to Pakistan.
一个月后，监狱工作人员把窗户涂上了油漆，可能是出于安全考虑，也可能是为了避免像你刚才听到那样的言论。安萨尔说，牢房变得像一座坟墓。在他被关押七个月后，移民局（INS）将他从监狱中带走，并将他驱逐到巴基斯坦。
A word of caution here. If you feel like you've heard stories like Ansar's before, you may have actually heard his. His family has become a poster child for groups who oppose the government's secret deportations.
这里要提醒一下。如果你觉得你以前听过像安萨尔这样的故事，你可能确实听过他的。他的家人已成为那些反对政府秘密驱逐政策的团体的海报人物。
I've been on ABC. I've been on CNN, BBC, PBS, UPN-9.
我上过ABC。我上过CNN、BBC、PBS、UPN-9。
Ansar's son, Uzer, who's 14.
安萨尔的儿子，乌泽尔，14岁。
We've been on an Italian TV show. We've been in a Spanish newspaper. All the newspapers you can imagine, we've been in them.
我们上过一个意大利电视节目。我们在西班牙报纸上出现过。所有你能想象到的报纸，我们都出现过。
So does that make you maybe think that your father's case was unusual?
那么这是否让你觉得你父亲的案子很不寻常？
Yes, it was unusual.
是的，这很不寻常。
His dad's case was unusual. Ansar was detained for seven months. The average time seems to be about two months. And the fact that his family didn't know where he was for weeks-- that seems to be very unusual.
他父亲的案子确实不寻常。安萨尔被拘留了七个月。平均时间似乎约为两个月。而且他的家人几周内不知道他在哪里——这似乎非常不寻常。
Uzer's dad did get his time before a judge. He was convicted of a felony for using an altered Social Security card and deported for overstaying his visa. It's worth mentioning that these are pretty common offenses. By the government's own estimates, there are over a quarter million people in the United States who have overstayed their visas and have been told to leave. So what brought 25 FBI agents to Ansar's door and not others? That's a mystery. But still, an overstayed visa is a deportable offense. As for all the secrecy, Uzer thinks it's because the government is embarrassed. It doesn't want to be seen picking on families like his.
乌泽尔的父亲确实在法官面前得到了他的时间。他因使用伪造社会保障卡被判重罪，并因签证逾期被驱逐。值得一提的是，这些是很常见的违规行为。据政府自己的估计，美国有超过25万人签证逾期并被告知离开。那么是什么让25名FBI特工来到安萨尔门口而不是别人？那是个谜。但即便如此，签证逾期也是可驱逐的罪行。至于所有的保密，乌泽尔认为这是因为政府感到尴尬。它不想被看到在欺负像他这样的家庭。
The government don't want to show its face. It doesn't want to get screamed at. It doesn't want to say sorry. Like people, when they hit somebody, somebody's going to say, say sorry to that guy. And they say, oh, I'm sorry. Even if they hate the person. They say, I'm sorry. Why can't you just say sorry? That's my question to the Bush administration right now. If they listen to this, I want to ask them to say sorry and give my house back and give my life back. It's not hard for them. They have a lot of money.
政府不想露脸。它不想被咆哮。它不想道歉。就像人们打别人时，总有人会说，给那个人道歉。他们说，哦，对不起。即使他们讨厌那个人。他们说，对不起。为什么你们不能说声对不起？这是我现在要问布什政府的问题。如果他们听这个，我想请他们道歉，把我的房子还给我，把我的生活还给我。这对他们来说并不难。他们有很多钱。
Uzer says life in Pakistan sucks. Neither he nor his brothers really speak the language. Kids at school have thrown rocks at them, calling them Americans, though of course they weren't real Americans, American citizens. Uzer and his brothers played basketball when they lived in New Jersey. I ask if they need a new ball. I can send them one. Uzer looks at me and says, man, what we need is a court.
乌泽尔说在巴基斯坦生活糟透了。他和他的兄弟都不会说这种语言。学校里的孩子会扔石头砸他们，叫他们美国佬，尽管当然他们不是真正的美国人，美国公民。乌泽尔和他的兄弟住在新泽西时打篮球。我问他们是否需要一个新的球。我可以送给他们一个。乌泽尔看着我说，伙计，我们需要的是一个法庭。
This is the part of the story where you would typically hear the US government's side of things, the government's take on what happened to Ansar and why they were investigating him in the first place. But of course, it refuses to discuss any of these cases. As a lousy second choice, I've brought along a tape recording of someone from the Department of Justice who spoke at a debate a while back. I'll play some of it for you in a little bit.
这是故事中通常会听到美国政府立场的部分，政府对安萨尔发生了什么以及为什么调查他的一面之词。但当然，它拒绝讨论任何这些案例。作为一个糟糕的第二选择，我带了一份司法部某人在不久前的一次辩论中讲话的录音。我一会儿会为你们播放其中的一部分。
The next deportee on the list is Huram Alta. I meet him at his parents' house in Islamabad. We sit on a couch and look over some family photos.
名单上的下一位被驱逐者是胡拉姆·阿尔塔。我在伊斯兰堡他父母家见到了他。我们坐在沙发上翻看一些家庭照片。
There's a few photos they sent me after-- that's my wife. That's my middle daughter and this is my son, the youngest one.
那是他们寄给我的一些照片——那是我的妻子。那是我的二女儿，这是我的儿子，最小的一个。
They're all sitting in a toy race car at a Chuck E. Cheese restaurant. While Huram and I talk, a guy named Wassim walks in. He's big and adorable. You could put him on a teen pinup poster. Wassim and Huram met in jail. Wassim is also on the ACLU list of appealing, mediagenic people kicked out of the United States. And he also has an ironic looking-out-the-jail-window story.
他们都坐在一家Chuck E. Cheese餐厅的玩具赛车里。当胡拉姆和我谈话时，一个叫瓦西姆的人走了进来。他身材魁梧，非常可爱。你可以把他放在青少年海报上。瓦西姆和胡拉姆在监狱里认识。瓦西姆也在ACLU的名单上，属于那些被赶出美国的、有吸引力的、上镜的人。他也有一段讽刺的、看着监狱窗外的故事。
And especially, I remember those little ducks. I saw six or seven little-- ducklings, right? Ducklings, and their mother duck. And I was like, aha, they are better than me right now.
特别地，我记得那些小鸭子。我看到六七只小的——小鸭子，对吧？小鸭子，还有它们的鸭妈妈。我当时想，啊，它们现在比我过得好。
But here's the thing. Talking to these guys, it seems like what they went through is no worse than the sorts of hassles immigrants in America have gone through with the INS for decades. Their stories don't explain the secrecy. In some ways, the two were treated well. Their families knew where they were. They got to make phone calls. Huram says the people in jail weren't mean or abusive. In the end, he was detained for two months, Wassim for one.
但事情是这样的。和这些人交谈，似乎他们经历的事情并不比在美国的移民几十年来与INS纠缠的麻烦更糟。他们的故事无法解释保密性。在某些方面，他们两人待遇还不错。他们的家人知道他们在哪里。他们可以打电话。胡拉姆说监狱里的人并不刻薄或虐待。最后，他被拘留了两个月，瓦西姆被拘留了一个月。
And did they get a fair hearing? Here, things get a little fuzzy. The Justice Department will tell you how all detainees are given lists of lawyers who will take their cases pro bono. And they all have access to law libraries and courts. And that's all true, except in practice, both men-- and a lot of these guys-- never got to see a judge. Huram and Wassim are what the INS calls absconders, people who according to its records had been sent letters ordering them to leave the country. The thing is, Wassim and Huram say they never got those letters.
他们是否得到了公平的听证？这里，事情变得有点模糊。司法部会告诉你所有被拘留者如何得到了一份自愿接手他们案子的律师名单。他们都有权使用法律图书馆和法庭。这些都是真的，但实际上，这两个人——以及很多这些人——从来没有见到法官。胡拉姆和瓦西姆是INS所说的“逃亡者”，即根据其记录，已收到命令离开该国的信件的人。问题是，瓦西姆和胡拉姆说他们从来没有收到过那些信。
Wassim's lawyer later told me that these are the sort of cases that can go either way. To prevent deportation, a lawyer has to convince an immigration judge to issue a stay and reopen the case. Wassim had some things in his favor. He's married to an American citizen and was working toward a green card, but since September 11, judges seem to be increasingly strict.
瓦西姆的律师后来告诉我，这些是可以有两个结果的案例。为了阻止驱逐出境，律师必须说服移民法官发出暂缓令并重开案件。瓦西姆有一些有利条件。他娶了一位美国公民，并正在争取绿卡，但在911事件后，法官似乎越来越严格。
I think it's fair to summarize the current US policy like this: if we can deport you, we will, just to be safe. Another guy I met in Pakistan says the INS told him his papers weren't in order and give him a choice-- go to jail, maybe for a year, and fight it, or get on a plane right now. He chose the plane.
我认为总结当前的美国政策是公平的：如果我们能驱逐你，我们就会驱逐，以保安全。我在巴基斯坦遇到的另一个人说，INS告诉他他的文件不齐全，让他做出选择——去坐牢，也许一年，然后打官司，或者现在就上飞机。他选择了飞机。
Huram pulls out another picture of his family. He and his wife have been lying to his kids, telling them that he's away working, that he had to go overseas.
胡拉姆拿出了另一张他家人的照片。他和他的妻子一直在欺骗他的孩子，告诉他们他在外地工作，他必须去海外。
For the first two months when I was in jail, we never told our kids that's where I was. But this thing is going to go in a bad impression on our kids. Now they know I'm in Pakistan, and they ask me, Papa, when are you coming home? Papa, when are you coming home? And I told them I'll be coming home soon.
在我坐牢的前两个月，我们从来没告诉孩子我在哪里。但这件事会对我们的孩子产生坏影响。现在他们知道我在巴基斯坦，他们问我，爸爸，你什么时候回家？爸爸，你什么时候回家？我告诉他们我很快就会回家。
Huram has been keeping up the lie for eight months now.
胡拉姆已经撒了八个月的谎了。
I get Wassim and Huram to pose for a picture, ask them to make their best sad-immigrant, please-let-me-back-in-the-United-States faces. They try, but can't stop laughing.
我让瓦西姆和胡拉姆摆好姿势拍了一张照片，让他们做出他们最悲伤的移民、“请让我回到美国”的表情。他们尝试了，但忍不住大笑。
When I try to imagine the government's point of view, I think about the plane that carried these guys back to Pakistan. Maybe most of the seats were filled with people like them. But what if, on the last seat in the back row, there was a terrorist. Was it worth it? After all, three of the September 11 hijackers were in this country illegally.
当我试着从政府的角度思考时，我想到那架把这些人载回巴基斯坦的飞机。也许大多数座位上坐着像他们一样的人。但如果，在最后一排的最后一个座位上，有一个恐怖分子呢？这值得吗？毕竟，911劫机者中有三个人是非法留在美国的。
On one of the last days, I go to meet Asma Jahangir, who works with the Pakistan Commission on Human Rights in the United Nations. It was some of her people who helped track down the deportees. She's a small woman who doesn't joke around much. This is a country where two women a day are killed, some burned alive, for dishonoring their families. Where it's illegal to speak ill of Islam. Where posters have been put up in phone booths, calling for Asma's death. 1/5 of Asma's employees are security guards, all carry big guns. I pull out a second tape recorder and play her part of the debate I've brought.
在最后几天里，我去见了在联合国巴基斯坦人权委员会工作的阿斯玛·贾汉吉尔。是她的人帮忙追踪到了那些被驱逐者。她是一个不苟言笑的小个子女性。在这个国家，每天有两名女性被杀，有的被活活烧死，因为玷污了家庭荣誉。在这里，诋毁伊斯兰教是违法的。在这里，电话亭里贴着呼吁杀掉阿斯玛的海报。阿斯玛的员工中有五分之一是保安，都带着大枪。我拿出第二个录音机播放我带去的辩论中她的部分。
This is Michael Chertoff, an assistant Attorney General of the United States. You heard him briefly in Jack Hitt's story. He makes a pretty powerful argument. She stares at the tape while it plays.
这是美国司法部助理部长迈克尔·切尔托夫。你们在杰克·希特的故事中简短地听到过他。他提出了一个非常有力的论点。当磁带播放时，她盯着它看。
There's the old expression in the context of the traditional criminal law that it's better that 10 guilty people go free than one innocent person should be imprisoned. And that's simply maybe an aphoristic way of making the point that we want to have the risk of error fall in favor of the one innocent person, even if it means that by mistake 10 guilty people don't get punished. But what do you do when the question is different? Is it worth having 1,000 innocent people killed to avoid having one innocent person suffer?
在传统刑法背景下，有一个古老的表达：与其冤枉一个好人，不如放走十个坏人。这只是一种警句式的说法，意思是希望将错误的风险转向有利于那个无辜的人，即使这意味着错误地让十个罪犯没有受到惩罚。但当问题不同时，你该怎么办？为了避免一个人无辜受苦，是否有必要让一千个无辜的人被杀？
Suppose you have Mohamed Atta, and you have some information about him. And you're sitting there and you decide, well, we don't have proof beyond a reasonable doubt yet, so we're going to let him out on bail until we collect it. And then he drives a plane into the World Trade Center. Would you really be willing to say it is worth the lives of 1,000 innocent people to keep one person from being detained for three or four months?
假设你有穆罕默德·阿塔，你有一些关于他的信息。你坐在那里决定，好吧，我们还没有排除合理怀疑的证明，所以我们要让他保释，直到我们收集到证据。然后他开车撞向世界贸易中心。你真的愿意说，为了防止一个人被拘留三四个月，让一千个无辜的人失去生命是值得的吗？
Asma taps a pack of Benson and Hedges on her desk. Mr. Chertoff, I can send you a tape, but here's her rebuttal.
阿斯玛在桌子上轻敲一包本森与赫奇斯香烟。切尔托夫先生，我可以给你寄一盘磁带，但这是她的反驳。
Your assistant Attorney General is very much sounding like our assistant Attorney Generals. He is giving an emotional example, which is not necessarily correct. It's like our Attorney General telling us all the time, we don't know who did it. We just have an idea that it is this place, so you round up 300 people and detain them and don't tell anybody about it. And we find that obnoxious. And I'm surprised that that kind of logic is being given to the people in the US and they are taking it.
你们的助理司法部长的声音听起来很像我们的助理司法部长。他给出了一个情感化的例子，这并不一定是正确的。就像我们的司法部长一直告诉我们的，我们不知道是谁做的。我们只是觉得是这个地方，所以你搜捕了300人并拘留他们，不告诉任何人。我们觉得这很令人反感。我很惊讶这种逻辑竟被灌输给美国人民，而他们竟然接受了。
Then Asma says something that catches me off-guard. She says this bothers her for another reason. When the US starts having secret trials and secret deportations, when human rights erode in the United States, it becomes harder for her to make the case for human rights here. If democracies don't respect human rights, she says, why should dictatorships?
然后阿斯玛说了些让我措手不及的话。她说这让她感到困扰是因为另一个原因。当美国开始进行秘密审判和秘密驱逐，当人权在美国受到侵蚀，她就更难在这里为争取人权进行辩护。如果民主国家不尊重人权，她说，独裁国家为什么要尊重？
The one central question all the deportees had while I was in Pakistan, the one thing that drove everyone crazy, was the question, why investigate me? Why was Wassim pulled over at 7:00 AM? Why did 25 FBI agents appear at Ansar's door? Most of the deportees felt the US government had singled them out, but this doesn't seem to be quite true. When I got back, I spoke with Muzaffar Chishti, director of the Immigration Policy Institute at NYU's law school. His group has been scouring the newspapers, talking to lawyers, to gather data on as many of these secret detentions as possible. They've now got information on some 400 people, about half the number picked up.
我在巴基斯坦时，所有被驱逐者提出的一个核心问题，那件让每个人都发疯的事情，就是这个问题：为什么调查我？为什么瓦西姆在早上7点被拦下？为什么25名FBI特工出现在安萨尔的门口？大多数被驱逐者认为美国政府专门挑出了他们，但这似乎并不完全正确。回来后，我与纽约大学法学院移民政策研究所所长穆扎法尔·奇什蒂谈过。他的组织一直在搜寻报纸，与律师交谈，以收集关于尽可能多的这些秘密拘留的数据。他们现在有大约400人的信息，大约是被捕人数的一半。
You know what a lot of them want to know? A lot of them want to know, why me? Why was I rounded up? Do you have an answer for them? I mean, you've looked at a bunch of cases. Do you know how it was the INS got onto most of these people?
你知道他们中的很多人想知道什么吗？他们很多人想知道，为什么是我？为什么我被搜捕？你有答案给他们吗？我的意思是，你看过很多案例。你知道移民局是怎么盯上大多数这些人的吗？
One would have to say that the bulk of these people were arrested on the basis of tips.
人们必须说，这些人的大部分是根据举报而被捕的。
Wow.
哇。
Which is, frankly, very unfortunate. I think what that shows is that people are called on people. Frequently neighbors called on neighbors. Frequently people who had business disputes with people called on people. People who had competitive business situations with people called on people.
说实话，这非常不幸。我认为这表明人们互相检举。经常是邻居举报邻居。经常是与人有商业纠纷的人举报人。经常是与人有商业竞争关系的人举报人。
So it wasn't like the police were running around, and the INS were running around, picking up anyone who looked like they might be a Muslim.
所以并不是警察在到处跑，移民局在到处跑，抓捕任何看起来可能是穆斯林的人。
I can't say that was the dominant story. I think the dominant story was people were calling in with tips.
我不能说那是主导情况。我认为主导情况是人们打来举报电话。
So it was us.
所以是我们自己人。
I think it frequently was us. And that obviously is another unfortunate tale about how we behave in a crisis and in an emergency like this.
我认为经常是我们自己人。这显然是关于我们在危机和这种紧急情况下如何表现的另一个不幸故事。
Why do you think the government was so secretive about this, if what they were doing is not something maybe they're terribly embarrassed about?
如果他们所做的事情并不是让他们感到非常尴尬的事情，你认为政府为什么要对此如此保密？
I really don't know. I mean, I think we--
我真的不知道。我的意思是，我认为我们——
I have to say that I felt like what they were hiding was not as bad as it might have been.
我必须说，我觉得他们隐瞒的事情并没有预想的那么糟。
Exactly, which is all the more reason to say that there was probably no reason to hide, except government agencies' arrogance that they don't have to reveal things.
正是，这更是理由说明根本没有理由隐藏，除了政府机构傲慢地认为他们不必透露事情。
Here's what I've been thinking. Secrecy is like a shot of Novocaine. It keeps you from having to feel anything. It blurs the chain of responsibility. We all want to believe our government is doing a fair job, that it's balancing the needs of security and fairness. We want to believe that someone from another country who's determined enough can make a life here, that those words engraved by the Statue of Liberty actually mean something. The secrecy saves us from having to think about it. It keeps the names and stories inked out.
这是我一直在想的。保密就像一针麻醉药。它让你不需要感觉任何东西。它模糊了责任链。我们都希望相信我们的政府在做公平的工作，它在平衡安全和公平的需求。我们希望相信一个来自另一个国家、足够坚定的人可以在这里创造生活，自由女神像上刻的那些字实际上是有意义的。保密让我们不需要去思考它。它让名字和故事被墨水涂掉。
David Kestenbaum is filling in as a producer on our show for a few months.
大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆正在填补我们节目几个月的制片人空缺。
Act Three, Secret Wiretaps From a Secret Court. We've had a secret court here in the United States since way before 9/11. It's called a FISA court. FISA stands for Foreign Intelligence Surveillance Act. It's a whole court system designed to do one thing: authorize wiretaps on people who may be foreign spies or foreign agents of some sort. And for 24 years since the court's creation, it has never said no to the government on any wiretap request, as best as anyone can figure out.
第三幕：来自秘密法庭的秘密窃听。我们这里有一个秘密法庭，早在911事件之前就在美国了。它叫FISA法庭。FISA代表《外国情报监视法》。整个法庭系统旨在做一件事：授权对可能是外国间谍或某种外国代理人的人进行窃听。在法庭成立后的24年里，据大家所能查到的，它从未对政府的任何窃听请求说不。
Then this past year, the court finally did say no, for the first time ever possibly, with an opinion that said that Attorney General John Ashcroft and the Bush Justice Department were going way too far. Note that the judges who said this were all conservatives, appointed to their positions by Chief Justice Rehnquist of the Supreme Court. The judges said that the Justice Department was trying to squeak its way around rules on wiretapping citizens that have been in place for decades now. They cited scores of abuses all done in the name of the War on Terror. The Justice Department, as you might expect, disagreed. A legal fight broke out. Blue Chevigny tells the whole story.
然后去年，法庭终于说了不，这可能是史上第一次，在一份意见书中说，司法部长约翰·阿什克罗夫特和布什的司法部走得太远了。请注意，说这话的法官都是保守派，由最高法院首席大法官伦奎斯特任命。法官们表示，司法部正试图通过狡辩绕过几十年来对公民窃听的规则。他们列举了以反恐战争之名进行的许多滥用行为。司法部，如你所料，不同意。一场法律战爆发了。布鲁·谢维尼讲述了整个故事。
Perhaps the most remarkable thing about this fight is that for the first time, it gives us a glimpse inside the FISA court. Up until now, we've known next to nothing. We didn't know where the secret court met. We didn't know when. We didn't know which government agencies were responding to wiretaps, or what they did with the information they got from the tapes. We didn't know who was getting tapped or exactly why. We did know, because it was part of the original law creating the court, that there were seven judges on the court at any time. They served a seven-year term and they were regular district court judges from around the country.
这场争斗最引人注目的地方也许是，它第一次让我们得以窥见FISA法庭的内部。直到现在，我们几乎一无所知。我们不知道秘密法庭在哪里开会。我们不知道什么时候。我们不知道哪些政府机构在响应窃听，或者他们对从磁带中获取的信息做了什么。我们不知道谁被窃听了，或者具体原因是什么。我们确实知道，因为那是创建法庭的原始法律的一部分，法院随时有七名法官。他们任期七年，都是来自全国各地的普通地方法官。
This is Ann Beeson, a lawyer at the ACLU and one of the people who's tried over the years to figure out what's going on inside FISA.
这是安·比森，ACLU的一名律师，也是多年来试图搞清楚FISA内部到底发生了什么的人之一。
Our understanding is that one judge would randomly get assigned to review an application for a surveillance warrant. And that judge would just look at the warrant-- I don't know whether he changed his robe, probably not-- and decide whether or not it was justified, under the standards in the FISA law.
我们的理解是，一名法官会被随机分配去审查窃听令的申请。那名法官只会看那个授权令——我不知道他是否换了法袍，可能没有——并根据FISA法律的标准决定它是否合理。
Some quick background. The FISA statute itself was a compromise that came out of the last big battle between privacy and national security in the 1960s and '70s. In the aftermath of Watergate and other scandals, a Senate investigation known as the Church Committee found that intelligence agents were routinely spying on and wiretapping people they shouldn't be-- like, famously, Martin Luther King, Jr.-- all in the name of national security.
一些简要背景。FISA法案本身是60和70年代隐私和国家安全之间最后一场大冲突后达成的妥协。在水门事件和其他丑闻之后，一个被称为“丘奇委员会”的参议院调查小组发现，情报人员 routinely（例行公事地）对他们不应该的人进行监视和窃听——比如著名的马丁·路德·金——所有这些都是以国家安全的名义。
Congress set up the FISA court to make sure that the people that were spied on were actually agents of a foreign power, but in a compromise with the Justice Department, the court was allowed to meet in secret. And also, the standard to get a wiretap through FISA was much lower than in a regular court. Specifically, the Fourth Amendment did not apply. You didn't need to show probable cause that a crime was being committed before you could do FISA surveillance.
国会设立了FISA法庭，以确保被监视的人确实是外国势力的代理人，但为了与司法部达成妥协，法庭被允许秘密开会。此外，通过FISA获得窃听许可的标准比普通法庭低得多。具体来说，第四修正案不适用。在进行FISA监视之前，你不需要证明有犯罪行为发生的“合理依据”（probable cause）。
The USA PATRIOT Act, which was passed quickly and mostly without opposition through Congress after September 11, changed everything. It altered the language in the FISA act by just one word, a familiar little word we use every day-- the. Before, FISA had stated that foreign intelligence gathering had to be the purpose of the surveillance. And now, it only had to be a significant purpose of it. What this wording change meant varied depending on who you talked to, but a lot of people feared that it gave the government too much spying power.
911事件后在国会迅速通过、几乎没有反对的《美国爱国者法案》改变了一切。它仅仅用一个词就修改了FISA法案中的措辞，一个我们每天都在使用的小词——“主要”（the）。以前，FISA规定外国情报收集必须是监视的“目的”。而现在，只需要是监视的“显著目的”（a significant purpose）之一。这个措辞改变意味着什么，取决于你和谁谈，但很多人担心这赋予了政府过多的监视权力。
Because of the the USA PATRIOT Act, they can listen in. If they really want you, they can just wiretap you without any probable cause that a crime has been committed.
因为《美国爱国者法案》，他们可以窃听。如果他们真的想要针对你，他们可以在没有任何犯罪发生的合理依据的情况下直接窃听你。
This is Congressman Bobby Scott, a Democrat from Virginia. He sits on the House Judiciary Committee and opposed the passage of the USA PATRIOT Act.
这是来自弗吉尼亚州的民主党众议员鲍比·斯科特。他身处众议院司法委员会，反对通过《美国爱国者法案》。
Now, I had an amendment, when it was being considered, that simply said that when the target stops using the phone, you have to stop listening. So if somebody else is using the phone, you can't just listen in on that conversation. My amendment was defeated, which means that if they know you're volunteering in the Democratic National Headquarters, they can drop a bug there and keep listening. But law-abiding citizens don't expect their meetings to be infiltrated. They don't expect their phone calls to be wiretapped. The fact that the amendment was defeated should alert people that there's more to this than fighting terrorism. Because the bill in the USA PATRIOT Act is not limited to terrorism.
现在，当该法案被审议时，我曾提出一项修正案，只是说当目标不再使用电话时，你必须停止监听。所以如果其他人在使用电话，你不能仅仅窃听那段谈话。我的修正案被否决了，这意味着如果他们知道你在民主党全国总部做志愿者，他们可以在那里放一个窃听器并继续监听。但守法公民不指望他们的会议被渗透。他们不指望他们的电话被窃听。修正案被否决的事实应该提醒人们，这比打击恐怖主义包含的内容更多。因为《美国爱国者法案》中的法案并不局限于恐怖主义。
Congressman Scott and others were afraid that the Justice Department would use the FISA court to get these easier secret FISA wiretaps and use them to spy on people who aren't terrorists or spies. But because none of their proceedings were public, nobody was sure how the FISA court was reading the word change. In August, a few members of Congress, most vocally Senator Patrick Leahy of Vermont, Chairman of the Senate's Committee on the Judiciary, decided to try to find out. He and other members of Congress wrote a letter to the FISA court, asking them for their take on the word change. And they got a reply. Ann Beeson of the ACLU tells the story.
斯科特众议员和其他人担心司法部会利用FISA法庭获得这些更容易的秘密FISA窃听许可，并用它们来监视那些不是恐怖分子或间谍的人。但由于他们的诉讼程序都不是公开的，没人确定FISA法庭是如何解读这个措辞改变的。8月，几名国会议员，其中最直言不讳的是参议院司法委员会主席、佛蒙特州的参议员帕特里克·莱希，决定尝试查明。他和其他国会议员给FISA法庭写了一封信，询问他们对措辞改变的看法。他们收到了回复。ACLU的安·比森讲述了故事。
The court said, oh, we're so glad you asked. It turns out that we issued a very important decision on precisely this point, of what the meaning of the PATRIOT Act is back in May. And now we've decided, now that you've asked us, that we should probably made that public, because it is really quite an important decision. And in fact, we denied the government's request for very broad new powers based on new PATRIOT Act language.
法院说，哦，很高兴你问了。原来我们早在5月份就针对《爱国者法案》的含义发表了一项非常重要的决定。现在既然你们问了，我们认为也许应该让它公开，因为它确实是一个非常重要的决定。事实上，我们拒绝了政府基于新《爱国者法案》措辞寻求的非常广泛的新权力。
What the senators had uncovered was the biggest courtroom drama you never heard of. It went like this. Attorney General John Ashcroft had interpreted the USA PATRIOT Act language as broadly as possible. That is, he said that now, under the new wording, the FISA court should authorize wiretaps in cases where criminal investigation was the main purpose, not national security. But the FISA court judges disagreed with his interpretation of the PATRIOT Act, and for the first time in history issued an opinion which said no.
参议员们所发现的是你从未听说过的最大的法庭戏剧。事情是这样的。司法部长约翰·阿什克罗夫特尽可能广泛地解释了《美国爱国者法案》的措辞。也就是说，他表示，现在根据新的措辞，FISA法庭应该授权窃听那些以刑事调查为主要目的，而不是国家安全的案件。但FISA法庭的法官们不同意他对《爱国者法案》的解释，并历史上首次发布了一份拒绝的意见书。
And the opinion itself is a remarkable document. Never before has there been a public opinion of the FISA court, ever. And the opinion documents a whole series of events leading up to it, which nobody knew anything about. They said, we think it's quite relevant to recite a history of abuses even before the government got new powers. In other words, even before it got this new power, it was doing things improperly. And we have documented that, and we have reprimanded some FBI officers, and in some cases even refused to let an FBI officer ever appear before the FISA court again because they were so distressed at this abuse of the power.
意见书本身是一份了不起的文件。在此之前从未有过FISA法庭的公开意见书。意见书记录了一系列导致此事的事件，对此无人知晓。他们说，我们认为列举政府获得新权力之前的滥用历史是相当相关的。换句话说，甚至在它获得这种新权力之前，它就在不正当地行事。我们已经记录了这一点，我们已经训斥了一些FBI官员，在某些情况下甚至拒绝让FBI官员再出现在FISA法庭面前，因为他们对这种权力的滥用感到非常苦恼。
The court cites 75 cases of abuse of the system. And to understand those abuses, remember that the original purpose of the FISA court was to prevent scenarios like this one. Let's say a criminal investigator thinks a guy is involved in drug activity, and he wants to do a wiretap on the guy, but he doesn't have enough evidence under the fourth amendment to do it through the criminal courts. So the criminal division guy calls up a friend, somebody in intelligence-- in the FBI for example-- and says, this guy is up to something and he might have ties to a foreign country anyway. Do me a favor and go to the FISA court and get them to authorize a wiretap.
法院列举了75起系统滥用案件。要理解这些滥用，记住FISA法庭的最初目的是防止类似这样的场景。假设一名刑事调查员认为一个人涉及毒品活动，他想对那个人进行窃听，但他没有足够的第四修正案证据通过刑事法庭去做。所以刑事部门的人打电话给一个朋友，情报部门的人——比如FBI——说，这个人有点问题，而且无论如何他可能与外国有联系。帮我个忙，去FISA法庭让他们授权一个窃听器。
To guard against that scenario, for 20 years the FISA court had put up what they called a wall. Regular criminal investigators and prosecutors couldn't go to foreign intelligence investigators and tell them who to tap. The 75 cases of abuse that the FISA court cited in its ruling were all instances where government officials had tried to breach that wall.
为了防范这种场景，20年来FISA法庭设立了他们所谓的“墙”。普通刑事调查员和检察官不能去外国情报调查员那里告诉他们窃听谁。FISA法庭在裁决中引用的75起滥用案例，都是政府官员试图冲破那堵墙的案例。
So the FISA court ruled against the Justice Department, and on the same day in August that they made their ruling public, they revealed something else. John Ashcroft and the Justice Department had not accepted the FISA court's ruling. There was an appeals process in the FISA statute, written in, in case of a major disagreement like this. But remember, there had never been a major disagreement before. The FISA court had never turned down a Justice Department request before. And so, for the first time ever, the FISA appeals court met. It's made up of three judges also convening in secret. Here's Ann Beeson.
所以FISA法庭做出了反对司法部的裁决，在他们使裁决公开的同一天，他们还透露了另一件事。约翰·阿什克罗夫特和司法部没有接受FISA法庭的裁决。FISA法案中写有一个上诉程序，以防出现像这样重大的分歧。但记住，以前从未有过重大分歧。FISA法庭以前从未拒绝过司法部的请求。因此，这是有史以来第一次，FISA上诉法庭开了会。它由三名同样在秘密中开会的法官组成。这是安·比森。
Again, a remarkable situation. Because here we have a decision that's on appeal to a secret court that, whether it does so directly or not, clearly involves the constitutionality of a major federal statute, giving the government new powers to spy on people all over the United States. And there's no one representing the side of the Constitution, because the only actual party in the proceeding and in the case is the federal government. For that reason, of course, the ACLU and a number of other groups immediately got together and knew we had to file some kind of brief.
再次是一个非凡的情况。因为这里我们有一个正处于上诉阶段的决定，提交给了一个秘密法庭，无论它是否直接这样做，显然涉及到一个主要的联邦法规的合宪性，赋予政府监视全美人民的新权力。而且没有代表宪法一方的人，因为诉讼和案件中唯一的实际当事人是联邦政府。出于这个原因，当然，ACLU和其他一些团体立即联合起来，知道我们必须提交某种简报。
Sounds simple enough. But consider for a second, this is a court whose operations are completely secret as a matter of national security, a court that no outside lawyer has ever filed a brief with.
听起来很简单。但想一想，这是一个出于国家安全考虑，其运作完全保密的法庭，一个从未有任何外部律师提交过简报的法庭。
Normally, in any other case, there are actually rules and very specific deadlines for when you can file this kind of a brief. The court's address and the clerk's name and everything is right there on the internet. In this case, nobody knows where it physically exists, even. Nobody knew. And therefore we had to go take this radical step of actually calling one of the judges directly, which is normally not even really proper, for lawyers to talk to judges directly.
通常情况下，在任何其他案件中，对于提交此类简报有具体的规则和非常具体的截止日期。法院的地址、书记员的名字和所有信息都在互联网上。在这种情况下，甚至没人知道它在物理上存在于哪里。没人知道。因此，我们必须采取这种激进的步骤，直接打电话给其中一名法官，这通常对于律师直接与法官交谈来说甚至是不礼貌的。
So we called. And it wasn't myself, actually, it was another colleague here at the ACLU. And he said, we're the ACLU and we know you're one of these FISA judges, and we want to file a brief. What do we do? And the judge said, I can't talk to you about this at all. He was sympathetic to the fact that we needed to communicate with someone. But he couldn't do it himself, and so he basically just got off the phone.
所以我们打了电话。其实不是我自己，而是我在ACLU的另一位同事。他说，我们是ACLU，我们知道你是这些FISA法官之一，我们要提交一份简报。我们该怎么做？法官说，我根本不能和你谈这件事。他对我们需要与某人沟通的事实表示同情。但他自己做不到，所以他基本上只是挂了电话。
About a week into this process, we learn that the court had set a secret hearing to hear the government's argument in the case. And we learned of it-- I think I remember it being on a Monday.
在这个过程中大约一周后，我们得知法院设定了一场秘密听证会来听取政府在案中的论点。我们获悉它——我记得是在一个周一。
The hearing was done, and the only oral argument the court heard was from the government. No one on the other side. Then the day after the secret hearing, Ann got a call from a woman identifying herself as a designated clerk of the FISA court, telling her the case wasn't over, giving her permission to submit the ACLU brief, and giving her an address for the court in a Justice Department building. Ann sent in their brief, and the court sent back an official letter, an order, saying they'd accepted it. She fished the order out of a stack of papers on her desk and showed it to me.
听证会结束了，法院听到的唯一的口头辩论是来自政府的。另一方没人。然后在秘密听证会后的第二天，安接到了一个女人打来的电话，自称是FISA法庭的指定书记员，告诉她案件还没有结束，准许她提交ACLU的简报，并给了她一个在司法部大楼里的法院地址。安提交了他们的简报，法院寄回了一封正式信件，一份命令，说他们接受了它。她从桌上的一堆文件中翻出那份命令，展示给我看。
So here's the order. And off to the left, it says, Number 02-001, showing that this is the first case that the FISA court of review has ever heard before. And I had this image of this court having never really issued public orders before, and of the judges directing their secretary to create a new template for the United States Foreign Intelligence Surveillance Court of Review, for the first time ever, because they'd never issued an order.
所以这是命令。在左边，它写着，编号02-001，显示这是FISA审查法庭有史以来审理的第一个案件。我有一个形象，这个法庭以前从未真正发布过公开命令，法官指示他们的秘书为美国外国情报监视审查法庭创建一个新的模板，这是有史以来第一次，因为他们从来没有发布过命令。
And it bears some resemblance to normal court orders. Normally, at the very top of a court order it would say the name of the court, and have their address and phone number and contact information. This order just says at the top, United States Foreign Intelligence Surveillance Court of Review.
它与普通的法院命令有些相似。通常，在法院命令的最顶部会有法院的名称，并有他们的地址、电话号码和联系信息。这份命令的最上面只写着：美国外国情报监视审查法庭。
She pointed to the top of the page.
她指着页面顶部。
And I was really amused, because whoever produced this order put the name of the court in this very gothic font. So it just looks like a parody of a secret court to me.
我真的感到被逗乐了，因为制作这份命令的人用这种非常哥特的字体写了法院的名字。所以对我来说，这看起来只是一个秘密法庭的模仿。
Two months went by. Then in November, on the 18th, the Court of Appeals issued its decision. It overturned the lower court and sided with the Justice Department's interpretation of the USA  PATRIOT Act. The ACLU had, in essence, lost the case.
两个月过去了。然后在11月18日，上诉法院做出了裁决。它推翻了下级法院的裁决，站在了司法部对《美国爱国者法案》解释的一边。ACLU基本上输掉了这个案子。
The court at least engaged in an analysis about whether or not the law was unconstitutional. But they did so in really quite a cursory way. And they only dealt really superficially with the argument that we made in our brief.
法院至少参与了一项关于法律是否违宪的分析。但他们以一种非常草率的方式进行了分析。对于我们在简报中提出的论点，他们也只是肤浅地处理了。
The most remarkable thing about the decision is, after they engage in this superficial analysis of how, oh, it's really not a problem that this doesn't meet the requirements of the fourth amendment, the decision actually says at the very end, that they realize the question is really hard and that it's probably true that FISA doesn't meet the standards of the fourth amendment. But it comes close enough, the court says. And it's just remarkable, this notion that it's OK for the government to just be close enough to the Constitution, but they don't actually have to comply with it.
关于这个决定最引人注目的地方是，在他们对这是否不是问题进行那种肤浅的分析后，即不符合第四修正案的要求，决定实际上在最后说，他们意识到这个问题确实很难，而且FISA可能确实不符合第四修正案的标准。但它足够接近了，法院说。这种概念真是太引人注目了，政府只要“足够接近”宪法就没关系，但他们实际上不必遵守它。
Do you have that  right in front of you?
你有那个就在你面前吗？
Yeah, I do.
是的，我有。
Can you actually read it?
你能实际读一下吗？
Yeah. It says, "We think the procedures and government showings required under FISA, if they do not meet the minimum Fourth Amendment warrant standards, certainly come close." And that's all they say.
好的。它说：“我们认为，FISA要求的程序和政府展示，即使它们不符合最低限度的第四修正案搜查标准，肯定也足够接近了。”他们说的就这些。
The court of review's action revolutionizes our ability to investigate terrorists and prosecute terrorist acts.
审查法庭的行动彻底改变了我们调查恐怖分子和起诉恐怖活动的能力。
Attorney General John Ashcroft, of course, sees things differently. This is from a press conference on the day of the appeals court decision.
司法部长约翰·阿什克罗夫特，当然，看法不同。这是在上诉法院裁决当天的新闻发布会上的讲话。
This will greatly enhance our ability to put pieces together that different agencies have. I believe this is a giant step forward.
这将极大地增强我们将不同机构拥有的信息拼接在一起的能力。我相信这是一个巨大的进步。
In his press conference, he didn't say much about the Constitutional questions raised by the decision, though he was asked. We wanted to hear more of the Justice Department's reasoning, so we decided to give them a call.
在他的新闻发布会上，他没有多说关于裁决提出的宪法问题，尽管有人问到。我们想听到更多司法部的推理，所以我们决定给他们打个电话。
Obviously, you want to do this to put on the radio, right?
显然，你想做这个是为了放在广播里，对吧？
Well, yeah.
嗯，是的。
OK. Let me check to see if I might--
好的。让我查一下看我是否可以——
This proved a lot more difficult than you'd think.
事实证明这比你想的要困难得多。
--and I'm sorry, I should have done this for you before, but I might be better off--
——我很抱歉，我本应该早点为你做这个的，但我可能最好还是——
It took two months of continuous phone calls. Finally an interview was set up with David Kris, a lawyer who worked on the Justice Department's brief before the FISA appeals court. We asked about the possibility that criminal investigators will start to label everyday Americans as threats to national security just to get a wiretap. And here's how he explained that it shouldn't be a big concern.
这花了两月的连续电话。最终与戴维·克里斯安排了一次采访，他曾在FISA上诉法庭前为司法部的简报工作。我们问起刑事调查员会开始给普通美国人贴上国家安全威胁的标签，仅仅是为了获得窃听许可的可能性。以下是他解释为什么那不应该成为大问题的原因。
This appeal does not change who may be a target of FISA searches or surveillance. That is the same now as it was before, and if you are not a foreign power or an agent of a foreign power, you may not be targeted under FISA.
此上诉并未改变谁可能是FISA搜查或监视的目标。这一点现在和以前一样，如果你不是外国势力或外国势力的代理人，你就不可能成为FISA的目标。
David Kris made this point several times. He slowed down when he said it. What has changed, he said, is something different, that the intelligence side and the criminal side can share information about cases and potential targets more freely. In other words, the wall is down. Which is fine if you trust the government will do the right thing with this power, or dangerous if you don't.
戴维·克里斯多次强调这一点。他在说的时候放慢了速度。他说，改变的是不同的事情，即情报方和刑事方可以更自由地分享有关案件和潜在目标的信息。换句话说，墙倒了。如果你信任政府会用这种权力做正确的事，这没问题；如果你不信任，这就很危险。
The ACLU has tried to figure out if there's any way to appeal the decision, to the Supreme Court, for example. It's a constitutional question at stake, after all But they can only bring a case if they find someone who thinks they were unfairly wiretapped under FISA, and there's not much chance of that, since virtually everyone tapped under FISA will never know they were.
ACLU试图找出是否有任何方法可以上诉该决定，比如上诉到最高法院。毕竟，这涉及到宪法问题。但他们只有在找到某人认为自己在FISA下被不公正窃听时才能提起案件，而这种机会微乎其微，因为实际上每个在FISA下被窃听的人永远不会知道他们被窃听了。
Blue Chevigny, from New York City.
布鲁·谢维尼，来自纽约市。
Well, our program was produced today by Alex Blumberg and myself with Diane Cook, Wendy Dorr, Dave Kestenbaum, and Starlee Kine. Elizabeth Meister runs our website. Production help from Todd Bachmann and Jane Golombisky.
嗯，我们的节目今天由艾力克斯·布隆伯格和我自己与黛安·库克、温迪·多尔、戴夫·凯斯滕鲍姆和斯塔莉·凯恩共同制作。伊丽莎白·迈斯特负责我们的网站。托德·巴赫曼和简·戈隆比斯基提供了制作帮助。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
Music help from consigliere Sarah Vowell. If you'd like to buy a cassette of this or any of our programs, visit our website, where you can get tapes or you can also listen to our programs for free, www.thisamericanlife.org.
音乐顾问萨拉·沃威尔。如果你想购买这一期或我们任何一期的节目磁带，请访问我们的网站，在那里你可以获得磁带，也可以免费收听我们的节目，www.thisamericanlife.org。
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. Funding for our show comes from the listeners of WBEZ Chicago. WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia, who keeps calling me at 3:00 in the morning to say:
《美国生活》由公共广播国际公司发行。我们节目的资金来自WBEZ芝加哥的听众。WBEZ的管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚负责，他经常在凌晨3点给我打电话说：
We're the ACLU and we know you're one of these FISA judges, and we want to file a brief. What do we do?
我们是ACLU，我们知道你是这些FISA法官之一，我们要提交一份简报。我们该怎么做？
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
PRI. Public Radio International.
PRI。公共广播国际公司。